Alright, we've looked at all of the individual
pieces of the critical rendering path. Now, let's
take a look at an end to end view and see how the timeline comes together.
>> Awesome, that's exactly what I need.
>> To keep things manageable we'll use our hello world page
that has a few inline CSS styles, some text, and image. Let's
refresh to capture the full trace. Okay, let's see what's going on
here. As you would expect, first we see the request go out
for the HTML document. Next, we get an event
showing that the server returned some response headers, followed by
some data. That's our HTML. Next up, the browser
begins parsing the HTML. This is where the browser is
converting the received bytes to the DOM tree, and
in fact, if we expand this note, you can see
that our document parser. Finds the embedded image reference
and initiates the request. Once that is done, it continues
to parse the HTML and once it gets to the
end it constructs the CSS object model. In this example
our CSS was inline directly into the page. So, there
are no CSS requests. Next, the browser builds the render
tree and computes all the styles for the content that
should be visible. On the screen. That's what this recalculate
style event indicates. Once that's done, we continue to layout,
which as you know now, is where compute the location and
the size of the render tree elements. Finally, once done, we
issue a paint event and our page is rendered on the screen.
>> You know, when we first started looking at everything, it felt
really confusing. But this is actually
pretty straight forward. This is pretty awesome.
>> Glad to hear